[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
down
[Music]
down
[Music]
down
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
has it really come to this
night city
[Music]
[Music]
used to be iron for higher still acts
like it
but the eddies are worth the risk trust
me
the more intel check the attachment
waiting on your sink thanks
whoa
think fleas like you just get in for
free
you got vip rooms here you know for
private shindigs
reserved for the boston call i think you
could use a little more company hmm
don't try to play me either i see
eddie's or your ass is walking
just chill or raid here
sweet jesus you hear that
do you hear what they're playing
each to their own johnny
that's what peeps with bad taste always
say
don't know what he did to deserve what's
coming but his music taste is reason
enough to drop it
all good
music in here is god awful
yeah i like it
beat keeps me awake
wanna have a word with your boss
oh you're out of luck
he doesn't really like the dog
i don't care if he likes to talk i asked
you if he was here
uh sure he's upstairs in the vip room
just don't expect a friendly vote
[ __ ] you going vip air is for vip you're
the boss we're type boss knows a lot of
peeps
sure [ __ ] ain't tight with a single one
yeah but
boss said to let nobody in wants an
alone time so cut the act
turn around [ __ ] gets ugly
ah
what the who the [ __ ] are you how'd you
get in here quiet down or i'll have to
cut our convo short oh i get it got a
bounty on my head have i
who hired you
milotech asukaga or was it that juan
cardino
sit down jack i'm extending a [ __ ]
courtesy here the fact that you're still
alive means i'm open to parley
paole vu go [ __ ] yourself chit chat's
for [ __ ] so let's get it over and
done with you versus me come on see you
win
say you put me out of commission you
think your problems will just vanish
into thin air you crawled under a lot of
people's skin said so yourself militech
asukaga dino they won't stop till your
head falls at their feet
so what i'm supposed to blow my [ __ ]
brains out no
all you have to do is leave night city
i'll tell him you took lead between the
eyes and none will be the wiser you can
start over a brand new life
yeah
start with what
everything i got's here my club
staff my girls and everyone who wants
you dead
this isn't a multiple [ __ ] choice
you're living on borrowed time
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bleeding [ __ ] [ __ ] was
that a yes or a no
just piss off and tell him the job's
done
straight ahead
[Music]
got someone else to follow
oh
i see you were following
then
foreign
i
was
ugh
go piss on me
heard whispers monster bit the concrete
nicely done
your boy dino needs a drink later be
good night and good luck
hello everyone welcome to red streams2
what you just saw was the first look at
gameplay from next-gen consoles of
cyberpunk 2077 and if you would like to
see some more you can head to our
youtube channel soon to to watch the
whole the whole gameplay from the next
gen consoles we will be talking to you
today about patch 1.5 and next gen
update yes finally
but before we get into it let's maybe
introduce ourselves so my name is alicia
i'm a community manager uh with me is
amelia who's a senior community manager
and she's gonna be playing the game for
us today hello everyone
we also have philip martinkowski our
gameplay qa hello my
friends and pavel the quest director yes
so as you know i'm just a random dude
with internet connection but i'm really
really
happy and excited to show you guys what
we have in store
yes and we have a lot of surprises
prepared so first of all we're gonna be
talking about about patch 1.5 that is
coming to all of the platforms that
cyberpunk is available at exactly
and it also brings the nextgen update
for ps5 and xbox series s and x
as well as a few free dlcs
on top of that just a few yes and we
will basically walk through those
yes
so
majority of their fixes and upgrades and
features that you will see in this uh in
the stream are coming to all of the
available platforms
uh but the next gen upgrade obviously uh
concerns the next-gen platforms
anyway maybe we should just jump in and
show you the changes that we prepared
okay
let's go
yeah exactly so uh as you guys see like
we heard uh online
a lot of feedback regarding the perks
right and and everything surrounding
that so one of the works that we've been
doing to actually
completely redo it and rethink it and
and look back and think exactly like how
we can actually do it better and there's
a ton of stuff that changed yeah exactly
uh basically we completely reworked our
perk trees but the first thing you
should notice here is that all of
perk's point are unassigned
and player if you continue your your
playthrough
on this patch
you are able to uh redistribute them
once more because our changes were so
vast that we have to
get all perks back to the player
okay so when i load my save game
basically i need to go back and
re-distribute okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
um and
the basic idea behind our changes in
trees in perks were was to
rebalance the game the combating game to
make it more fair
um and
as well as get rid of some not that
useful perks we got for example this
famous perk
about
preventing detection underwater
so that that was my favorite one i was
always using it so yeah unfortunately
unfortunately you were the only one
i was the only one that's using it okay
as always maybe you'll find a new
favorite yeah so we scrub them and uh
add some new that we find more
interesting okay okay so
so i expect like that i can now
basically make my like dildo build
really effective right that's basically
what you're going to tell me philip yes
yes
we make sure that your build the build
will be uh
effective as never before okay so what
other specific examples can we can we
show our viewers now
for example in uh cool perk trees
uh we've got
ninjutsu instead of stealth
um okay and here here is the perk uh
dagger dealer
and it reintroduced our uh throwing
knife combat loop but we will elaborate
on this later
um and this uh in this tree we've got
this this perk about being detected and
underwater blah blah blah
but now you have a looking sharp
perk that enhances throwing knives
sharp
yeah yeah
uh okay
and here we have uh cold blood perk tree
as you can see and this is a perk blood
swell
previously
it gains only immunities for the player
like immunity for
burning
poison etc and now now we gave you a new
ability to survive a final blow so if
you think about it
you can
build around that uh
different play style let's say we
encourage you to to play more aggressive
to to play fast not to use covers
so it's it's opportunity to um
to play like that
oh i see so basically like now i can as
a player i can really like
try completely different play style so
to say right like just
play in a different way basically with
these changes exactly and i gave you
only a few examples of our changes but
there's a lot a lot more there and i
encourage you to to check them try them
i mean definitely guys when you put up
the game after 1.5 remember to check out
the perks check out what we changed what
we uh what we uh
rebalanced
and redistribute all your perks because
otherwise you can just
get one shot by a random npc
okay you were mentioning the throwing
knives and i think it's the time exactly
check it out in action so i'm going to
yeah
equip some of those
uh so basically uh we make sure that you
will no longer lose your knife once
drawn
okay so so how does it work exactly like
it works like a boomerang let's say
because once you throw a knife it get
back to you and okay so it's like a
classic cyber knife i get it okay so so
this this little circle in the middle
shows us exactly it takes it to come
back it's a it's a cool down for uh
coming back and it's different
regardless of uh depending on uh rarity
of the knight
if you got
legendary knife it will come back uh
faster
yeah okay i had no idea okay this is
really awesome and this ui element
basically that is appearing now at the
center right after throwing the knife
yeah it it shows you it shows you when
it gets back but yeah it's a timer
basically right it's a timer yeah but
you can you can approach the knife you
throw and get it back so it is this part
that encourages you to to play fast
uh i see so i don't have to like wait
for my knife to be back i can just
approach it and grab it right okay okay
okay really nice if you combine perks
from ninjutsu with cold blood you can do
it
without
harm basically
okay i think amelia found some more
dudes
yeah but actually we were speaking about
the the knife throwing but there are
also a lot of changes to uh to the
combat ai of npcs in general so would
you guys like to elaborate on that yeah
yeah there's a lot of changes that makes
ai in combat more
effective let's say
enemies reacts better to player actions
they
find covers more effectively they exit
them if we are flanking them
so
it's hard to show examples here on our
stream but if you try the game you will
feel that there is a lot of changes in
quality
yeah and i really want to like in this
point like just give a lot of credit to
our gameplay team because they did a ton
of small changes here to basically make
the npcs be more clever be more
effective during combat and we really
like encourage you to just give it a
shot try it out you know see what
actually now npcs can do and and you
know how fluid the combat feels now
okay sounds good and
i think those guys left some motorbike
bikes you know uh and nobody's here
you want to grab it or something yeah i
wanna i wanna take one the yellow one
take this one
yeah so
here is a first change
we've got nail dreams now in what in
every bike in the game you've got yeah
it's it's a it's a it's a basically a
small add-on so to say but how do you
actually cycle through that amelia how
did you like enable that
so i pretty much pressed elastic on
the controller but if you play on your
keyboard pretty much just press e and
they will be on
beautiful
okay in cars it is for toggling
lights
and and on bikes you you you turn your
own rims on
yeah and it's like we can do something
more i see you very well wait i haven't
seen that before
it's it's time to
talk a little bit about driving model
because in 1.5 patch
there is a lot of changes
about driving model in our game yeah we
can see what amelia can do now yeah so
here you can see a reworked burnout
model that you
you can you can do it uh
more easily and you
have a little fun with uh burning out it
might work and i can do it on the cars
and the motorcycles right yeah every
changes uh are about bikes and
cars as well so okay
you mentioned cars and i i have to
i have to check it out
yeah
the driving model generally is more
predictable
the vehicles feel a little bit heavier
we
we make breaking better we simulate abs
for example
[Music]
also there is a opportunity to perform
drifts when you take the corners
and i feel like the the suspension also
feels better in the cars yeah in 1.5
exactly and
suspension was added to the traffic cars
as well so you can observe that they
they're moving on
on the on the on the suspension
what i like the most
uh is that each model of car feels and
bike feels a little bit different
and
it's and it encouraged me to to try
different different models and find the
the
ones i liked the most yeah someone
didn't like my car and just crushed it
this is definitely something for the
community to try out for themselves and
check out like which car would be their
favorite which would feel the best but
this there is one thing i noticed that
amelia actually
uh
called a lot of vehicles and they they
landed in different places so they don't
they don't crash at one at one place
right now anymore yeah i mean so
we know that it was a bug right like we
we know that it was a bug that needs
addressing and of course you know we
took care of it so finally it works
properly uh right now
but i'm also seeing more changes
actually right now when amelia's driving
yeah one of the first person
one of the major improvement is that uh
is visibility
in a first person perspective when we're
driving a car
so we
we we tweaked them and now you can see
the road in each model
so you can enjoy first person view when
driving and enjoy these beautiful
dashboards that are exactly really
interesting yeah i remember i think the
villa fort was like particularly bad
before yeah like i couldn't see [ __ ]
from the car i also was like so low that
they felt like my ass is like brushing
the asphalt literally yeah so
uh some i'm glad that actually like i
can now you know enjoy it in first
person because before it was kind of
challenging to drive in first person
it was a pity because this car was a
reward from one of the mission
and and
now you can you can feel it in 100
and yeah and we can do the burnout as we
can see and do the donut as well in the
cars right oh i definitely need to try
it once once yes it's live because this
looks freaking amazing i wouldn't be
able to do it in real life but here
maybe
you should try you should try it's safer
this way to not do it in real life
maybe maybe one day
i will show you later
talk to the dudes by my window you know
because people do exactly that you know
in warsaw so hey um
that unfortunately happens but we have
also done
more changes you know when it comes to
the
crowds and traffic in general right
yes
we make the city more living let's say
that uh for example we introduced uh
aggressive crowds crowds
crowds that can react to your action
your aggressive action and here you can
see that
one of the crowd starts shooting at you
because you point car uh
gun at uh
they actually agreed some uh some of the
normal ulcers yeah
yeah yeah yeah thank you guys
yeah it's a it's a pretty cool thing
like just it brings up a bit more
reactivity and life uh to the city the
fact that like some of the crowds some
of the people are actually armed and
they may decide to actually attack you
at the moment when you when they like
threaten them in some ways yeah and here
you can see that animation of running is
more
more smooth let's say
uh crowds no running crowds no longer uh
on stream when you turn camera away no
they don't disappear they don't despawn
basically when you like make a 360
basically this is what you use it was
amazing we could actually see them
running the other way from you once you
once once we went further than them
yeah yeah and and also
we introduced changes in crowds but also
in traffic so uh we've got oh
okay so let's let's look at what happens
to the traffic then we call it panic
driving and
basically we do the same as
with kraus so so
drivers can react to players actions
they can run drive away
uh from the player
who if you are aggressive towards them
yeah
that's an example of just like simply
gang attacking us and following us yeah
yeah yeah
but not okay i need i need more cars
guys i need more cars exactly like so i
think we can showcase something else
right like our our cycle
oh you can't skip time because you're in
combat
yeah you need to get away okay
i'm just gonna
kill this
oh you're accurate but basically what we
have introduced is like the fact that
right now when you cycle through the uh
to the time which i think amelia
actually can do right now yes is that uh
the the crowds will actually change here
you have one of our quality of life
improvements
yeah we we definitely redesigned the ui
of uh of the skip time mechanic so you
can now more clearly see which time you
will be skipping to
and you you don't have to do the math uh
which yes
which hour will be when you skip uh
six hour hours forward yeah so i see
that we skipped time to like the uh
middle of the day and now the streets
are actually more full than they were
during the night
crowds and traffic is uh reloaded this
bye bye just drove over that guy
poor fella
okay
i think this is philip would you have
called just before a panic driving
correct
yeah exactly exactly
yeah you can see this guy exactly like
because we have started shooting he
decided [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm moving away
from here
i mean they tried but i can see that
they they even crashed a little bit so
the
drivers can crash into obstacles and for
example lose consciousness uh in front
of the wheel so yeah
the cars can crash into themselves the
crash can actually i think like drive
over pedestrians as well that also
happens uh yeah exactly oh yeah here you
have an example of like that uh driver
decided to
get the hell out of here
yeah
i think this guy is
oh yeah he probably lost consciousness
there yeah okay amelia do you think
maybe maybe we've had enough of like uh
mayhem in the middle of the city
did we okay i think whoa
oh that's one of the examples actually
when like during the panic driving they
can actually drive on the pavement and
drive on a pavement when and of course
you know they can drive through the you
know lamp posts and all that stuff when
they try to get away from you and you
can also like i think what philip
mentioned that you can also like follow
them and basically see you know what
what the
drivers do
okay so
but i see amelia has opened them up to
to like
find her way home and we actually have a
couple of changes on the map like some
new colors were added
yeah so there's actually lots of like
smaller quality improvements here that
contribute to this picture so first of
all of course you know the map in
general was refreshed the icons were
replaced now you actually very clearly
see the site content from the main
content
yes so the site content is now this uh
this greenish greenish hue and the main
main quest main gigs are still the
yellow ones so you can clearly clearly
see which ones are which
exactly basically the green color is is
is uh from the fixers
yes
exactly
exactly and you can see here and you can
see here like basically undiscovered
gigs are just gigs this is basically
boosting a bit of a sense of a discovery
for you as a player okay what it is
before you you could basically kind of
tell you know what it is now before you
actually discover it you don't know but
there is actually more
yeah speaking of fixers right now as we
we see now he has the counter of of the
gigs that he that can be completed for
him
and besides that we don't also get all
of the gigs at once from from the fixer
so we need to earn some standing by
completing some gigs for them before
they can give us more of those
exactly and that basically in general
like contributes to this overall feeling
of me as a player like sv in a mercenary
night city actually progressing you know
uh when i'm actually like gaining the
street cred and gaining experience in
the city doing the gigs and whatnot i'm
gaining that standing as you can see
basically that reputation with a certain
fixer um
and basically more jobs more interesting
jobs actually unlock as you progress
but they also they also have a reward
for you once you complete all of the
gigs for specific fixer
right yes that's true actually so uh
that basically is an encouragement uh
for you as a player to actually try out
there are new rewards uh that we have
added a completely custom pretty cool uh
rewards that we have added for you uh to
try out basically so uh uh that a fixer
will basically contact you and you know
you will know what to do and how to get
your uh reward from there i guess we
don't have to spoil them yeah and it's
also worth mentioning that we added
filters to the map so you are no
overwhelmed with all icons at the same
time you can filter through them
and the filters were visible at the left
corner of the map just a moment ago so
we can like cycle through this and
basically see the um
see you know all the site content all
the uh you know activities coming so the
white icons basically so let's say you
know vendors or ripper dogs or whatnot
joy toys obviously yeah
as well
yes so it definitely declutters them up
a lot so you can you can only see the
most important things that you are
looking for at the moment uh anyway as
we are heading to home uh maybe we
should we should somehow is it
because we mentioned some of the changes
that are coming with 1.5 uh
the combat ai as well as crowd behavior
and drivers ai is getting smart smarter
it's getting uh it has more more diverse
reactions to what v does in night city
we also have driving model driving
models don't forget
of course that's very important
uh but also also now we have we have
working knife rowing which actually
brings the whole new playstyle to the
game we reworked a lot of perks and
changed some stuff in the perk trees
uh
i have to i have to mention one more
thing that not only combat is rebalance
but also economy in the game so you you
rewards are
bigger you get more cash and uh prices
are also rebalanced so for example
vehicles are not that expensive as in
line 1.3
so it's easier to easier to buy stuff
for example you you don't have to choose
between them right you can finally get
that achievement then yeah
exactly and while we talk about economy
i think wilson has something for us
because you know look at his store it's
like oh bread
looks like cell
looks like wheels on sale wilson wilson
is having a first sale it seems that the
inflation has hit him badly um so you
can see here like a bunch of new
decorations of course you know we have
like updated that bit so um what what
what we can actually expect from wilson
now well first of all let's let's just
say that this is actually the first dlc
that we are introducing in 1.5 because
clearly clearly we are adding some new
stuff uh and the new stuff are
so pretty much i i sort of cheated
before the stream and i already visited
wilson i'm sorry
but i already bought like two new
weapons so it's the guillotine in umbra
uh but they come in like different
colors different varieties as you can
see uh but i think i think we can do a
little magic
time again
so basically he he has two new rifles
with different appearance appearances
we've got new scopes and
muzzle breaks that enhances uh ricochet
bullets
um handyman okay so so how does his shop
work because like i see that after
actually skipping this this time and
actually waiting a bit uh it seems that
his stock has changed right and we see
this like new label right on those icons
that basically communicate to the player
that this is a new stock but how
basically the store works
this dlc
these dlc is enabled at the beginning
basically at the beginning of the first
act of the game we have to meet takamura
at tom diners
oh yeah don't leave him hanging
basically don't leave him please
not like in the mems
and after after this scene we get we are
informed by wilson
by text message that he has sailed and
we when we are approaching him for the
first time
most of the items from dlc
and and uh
when we visit him later on it will be
randomized so yeah and we can cheat that
as we see like amelia did by simply
skipping time so he has time to restock
uh on on the guns and on the new stuff
yeah oh okay oh so that's that's
guillotine
yeah okay that's pretty sweet
okay
i think that
i think that you know our players can
just like you know um
after getting the uh the update uh just
have fun with it and just check out we
don't have to showcase everything uh
because we like to leave some secrets oh
yeah definitely
exactly
they're nice colors as well
so so you also can randomize them cheat
the time like skip the time and then you
will get all of the new colors like
collect them all right
yes it's because we're not that
expensive either so you can afford yeah
as we are moving to the through the um
uh mega blok i just wanted to mention
something like we have also done like
one of the bigger quality of life
improvements which is actually option to
reject holocaust
at the moment when
anyone from actually side content in the
game will call you right now as a player
you have an option to reject it before
it was not possible and in that case
actually this given npc will follow up
with you with a custom text message um
in case of actually bigger and more
important npcs those will be more
customized messages and so on i will
leave it for you uh to discover but it
was an important change for us to make
it is actually in settings that you can
by default reject some of the calls like
the police commissioner or something cpd
dispatcher yes this button actually
registered
muted
exactly okay can i go home now yeah
well i think oh yeah that's something
that we definitely want to show you it's
being spoiled on the screen right now
so uh
not anymore basically what we added is
the ability to change your appearance
mid game
in in in the mirror in this apartment so
here we go
interference but how does it work so is
that is it just it right like is there
anything more uh to it
oh yeah definitely i mean i mean we have
all the options that were available to
you uh
before like when it comes to hair color
or or makeup styles in the character
creator but we also added a bunch of new
uh new options for like hair or makeup
and stuff like that so as you can see
now we have a bunch of new colors i
think amelia is going to choose one of
them because they're come on they're
beautiful yeah okay so just yet
exactly show us some some new ones so
this is this is one of the new ones
right like
yes
yes we do that's another one that's
another one finally what's also cool
that you can actually choose the style
of your of your uh lipstick so it's
either either glossy or
matte
or mud definitely yeah
this is what i'm talking about
i think glossy is also my choice yeah
and also also we have so many new
beautiful makeup options for your eyes
oh as you can see amelia is quickly
going through them but definitely you
guys need to check them out
and they're not only available here in
the mirror but you can also like if you
decide to create the new character from
from the start uh
then it's also available in character
creator at the beginning of the game
with an improved lighting as we can see
now it's much more natural than it used
to be
yes okay for sure okay i'm just going to
quickly go for hearts
actually that's beautiful
yeah we have also added like a small
touch like a more of like a narrative
touch here basically after changing it
you can see basically looking at herself
in the mirror um you know just
give it more of a feel okay
let's uh
okay we need we need to we need you to
show us your your own like makeovers uh
after after you have the patch uh
downloaded because because we're we're
curious what we
i was talking to the viewers but yeah
philly
red lipstick red lipstick
exactly let's let's jump on it um okay
but it's so so that was basically a
second dlc as far as i'm aware right
like but that's not all right like we
also have the third one the first one
here
and the third one is a pretty pretty big
it's actually you know we've been
talking about this makeover and now we
go to home makeovers yes
exactly so we have added basically a new
website in your computer on this
apartment called easy estates
and uh here you have two different
options as i can see for rent and and
renovations and makeovers
we're gonna we're gonna go for makeovers
first because our v just got my cover so
i think the flat also you know uh
requires someone
you know amelia which one would fit with
the pink and i don't know her i don't
the pink flamingo one pink fluffy okay
all right okay so here basically after
uh choosing a certain makeover you can
see basically in large pictures so that
you as a as a player you can basically
see okay does it feel you know does it
work for me um can i express my
masculinity fully uh using this pink uh
makeover you know so he can hear he can
do it okay let's let's see it in the
in the full glory
okay yeah let's let's look at it it's
definitely pink
and it's green but it cost us only 10k
so you owe me 10k
okay let's talk after the stream okay
right so as you can see basically like
the the whole apartment sort of gets a
pretty uh decent i would say repaint and
you have like as we said six styles
right
pick from cool so so whichever
represents you best you can pick one of
those
yeah but there's also more on the
website
so let's go back
yeah let's go back and actually
basically this option this one
this option was for the players who
really love like the base vs apartment
in the mega blok
but and mega building but there's more
so we introduced four new apartments for
you to rent and each of them is located
in different places in night city so
basically whichever whichever fits you
best whichever
uh whichever is
good for your pocket because uh as we
can obviously see the corpora one in
corpora plaza is is 55k so so it's a lot
more expensive than than the other one
in japan town for example which is i
think only 15k
yes and i'm gonna go for this one
because you took my 10k and i'm i cannot
afford corporal plaza anymore all right
okay so when we were actually looking
into the design of the apartments for v
we thought about actually like uh for
the player be able to to be able to
express their own
identity as v so let's say you play as v
as a corporal right maybe i actually
really want that corporal plaza and just
really have that you know corporate life
or maybe when you play a street kid
maybe you would prefer the japan town
and so on i encourage you really to try
out you know different apartments and
see you know for what what works best
for you
okay but um
i already forgot where i have to go so
i'm gonna
check yeah so this is just one of the
small quality of life improvements that
we have introduced for you guys uh the
uh in the journal you have now the
apartment stop you can go there you see
all of those apartments with actually
nice uh flavored descriptions you can uh
basically track a certain quest you know
to get there
you don't have to use the website though
to uh rent the apartment you can
actually do it uh at the place you have
a separate scene you know that
introduces you into it again just a
small quality of life thing we didn't
want to force you you know to run to the
apartment and do that
yeah so either either by the website in
this apartment or you just you can just
stumble onto those apartments uh across
this the city yeah
it's worth adding that we've got what
this dlc is
enabled
similar to the wilson sail dlc so after
after the beginning of the first act of
the game after takamura team
so i think we have a question from the
chat from mac beefy
does nibbles follow you home to the new
apartment
no actually ebos doesn't uh and nibbles
does not follow you to the to the new
apartment and ibus is really a keen of
your uh apartment in the
um
in mega blok however nebo's also got
some new secrets to uncover uh because
this patch is actually packed with uh
things that we won't talk about uh and
uh things that are not even included um
anywhere uh and it's only for you to
find so um we made sure that there's
something uh for you to find regarding
this as well but i won't say anything
more so
i'm just saying that he prepared
something that nobody knows about it
even in the company
i think only i think one person and one
qa knows what we did so it's like
probably three people
know about it
so night city has some new secrets to be
discovered for you guys right after the
match
and now wait wait
now now miles will kill us all because
fast travel
yeah very nice if you're watching
the time you know we have to fit all of
that into into this short stream but the
next time we will be in night city we
will definitely take a
nice slow walk because
because you can do it
because you can
because you can because we added a walk
button work toggle to pc so basically
you can you can now just uh just walk
slowly and admire night city while doing
that
yes
in night city yeah yeah you can flex
walking i mean but it's not really like
a huge feature or anything but we know
you guys wanted it right like it was
highly requested of course you know we
we have added it just to be sure that
you you you know you can feel that we
really listen um but then we ended up in
our new place yes we ready
so let's let's go and let's see it
i'm gonna close my eyes i'm gonna close
my eyes
just just hit that
right so first time when we actually get
to your apartment there's this small
video that will introduce you uh to it
um but then of course you know uh you
can
move around and actually enjoy uh the
place so
i think here we can also mention uh work
that our environment art team has been
doing actually preparing those
apartments
okay uh so actually i can see that we
have another question from the chad um
and it's asking do you need to pay rent
for that or buy these apartments and the
answer is very simple this is a one-time
payment for the apartment so you rent it
rent it you pay it one time and it's
yours so corporal plaza you pay 55k once
and it's yours this japan town it's a
little bit cheaper just 15k and it's
yours so it's it's pretty good price i
think
exactly
when amelia was like moving through the
flat we saw that there's a bunch of new
interactions uh that we have actually
added in the flat or for youth for the
player for pretty much role playing so
let's uh check some of them okay
i'm gonna gonna do this
incense
yes so basically the interactions that
you have in those different departments
those are small things but they are all
basically contributing to you as a
player to the feeling of really
role-playing and being in a night city
and really enjoying it that's something
that a lot of players really asked for
and we felt uh that it was of course a
very reasonable uh request that's why
you know when working new apartments we
actually added it
now can we can also yeah let's play the
guitar because actually the chat is
demanding we play
let's play the guitar
what tune we have to play your mom
what what song
oh my gosh the first one the first one
the best one so the best one okay this
is the best one obviously it's a
it's a difficult choice
and here here you can see uh the design
design from 80s basically it's a
headless guitar
it's a
close to the
design
yeah and i have here i have to uh
appreciate work from our animators and
cinematic artists
because uh i really like how they um how
they make uh
moving
fingers on a fretboard because it's
pretty accurate
right and left hand works really really
good really accurate so i this is this
is a small little touch but i like it
very much do you okay but what else we
have in the apartment right because it
was cool you know to sit down and chill
and and whatnot but i think there is
more uh oh yes yes yes
so while we are showing something more
we have another question uh whether you
can own all of the apartments at once
and
yes if you're if you're very [ __ ]
filled too rich yes
of course there's no limit you can
actually own all of the apartments so
feel free to do it do you need you just
need enough addis to that to do that
yeah so
talking about those interactions that we
have added there's actually
more things that we've done right
because some of those actually give you
buffs
yeah but maybe let's talk about that one
first i think someone was asking about
it we have the stash right there on the
right no
sure we we can we can also really
quickly talk about the the stash so
basically apartments come in with the
stashes and here we have basically
introduced uh
another quality of life improvement that
uh all the stashes in all the apartments
are actually shared so now as a player
basically wherever whichever apartment
you have uh but wherever weapon you will
place you can actually place it there
and they all actually show up on the
wall we paid attention to that because
we thought it's important a lot of
players really love to collect all those
guns um on the walls so here you can do
it and also
they are connected with stashes in
players vehicles so yes this is the
whole
whole web of stashes
it's all together okay now we can go to
sleep and showcase you that some of the
activities in the apartment actually
give us uh
buffs yeah for example sleeping
give you back to
experience points for skills
um
exactly there's uh yeah and there's
bunch more actually that we will we will
just leave the players to discover but
talking about sleeping right i need to
tell you about something so we know that
you guys are
really loving the romances right in our
game and you're like really liking the
characters so we looked back in our
romances into our four romance partners
and we introduced a bunch of new uh
changes and improvements there and one
of the things that um
you can do right now is uh throughout
the development of the relationships
with those characters you can actually
message them way more often uh
throughout the whole development of that
romances and it's done differently for
each character we wanted to we paid
attention to the personality of a
certain character there's bunch of new
things to discover there which i won't
talk about um i'm sure that someone will
eventually uh find it and encourage you
to talk to um your partners but as you
know when you go uh when you become a
partner with someone that place of that
uh that person's place becomes a safe
house and that safe houses actually
got some improvements
okay so what what what happened there or
we don't want to spoil that
maybe i don't want to spoil it but one
thing we can mention maybe we can
mention uh the option to
uh when you're going to sleep uh you as
a if you're a partner with someone let's
say judy uh there is a uh chance uh i
won't spoil how it's done exactly but
there's a chance that you wake up next
to your beloved person and then there's
more uh things actually connected to
this those are small touches basically
it's nothing really major but those are
small touches throughout the whole
storylines of those characters that
basically make you feel really that
you're closer to that characters and
also they they give you like a proper uh
sort of a continuation to that woman's
story arc and i know that a lot of you
requested that i mean and it's just in
time for valentine's day which was
yesterday so
perfect timing okay uh
yeah i need a shower because i'm
completely smashed okay because i drank
all my whiskey so
i'm just gonna
walk in here
yeah so this is one of the one of the
fixes that we have done
yes which means we is actually taking
her clothes off in the shower right yeah
exactly so like that's the thing like i
remember i went to reddit like one at
one point and i was shocked to discover
that you guys shower undressed right
like that was that that was not really
uh you know something that came to my
mind right away but apparently most
people uh shower with no we have no
clothes so we decided we need to we need
to change it right don't tell me you
actually shower in your clothes
i i i do that randomly you know just
depends but anyway it was obviously it
was obviously an issue that we have
fixed yeah okay but also i can see that
the shower shower actually gave us
another buff yeah exactly we can see the
buff and also i think amelia just passed
next to the mirror right amelia maybe we
could take a look at that because one
thing i wanted to mention is like aside
of those you know interactions that
allow you to role play a bit more and
just really feeling like being in a
night city as a player you also have the
mirrors in all of the apartments where
you can actually access the uh option to
mod uh your own appearance yeah so right
now actually johnny messed it up a
little bit for us
no
but in general uh all of the apartments
have the mirrors where you can customize
your character mid game
yeah johnny is here of course
intentionally right because like as his
uh a long time memory slowly leaking to
your short term memory and your
personalities are merging and whatnot he
basically starts to uh starts appearing
in the mirrors uh so that's of course
intentional that's that's not the bug as
uh i've seen uh sometimes people claim
uh that was of course intentional and
here in that case you know from time to
time johnny will appear and you could
see that amelia was actually able to um
get into the into the modding of the uh
of the face again and change the light
okay but speaking of johnny uh we
actually went through like three
different dlcs which are the new guns
for the new apartments for v the new
uh new customizations to to this uh to
this uh look yeah yeah
but we also added uh a dlc for johnny
and yes we did
so so basically we added a few a few new
uh photo mode poses for him so now
whenever whenever you are in the
uh in the scene uh in his memories when
you are playing as journey you can you
can take uh take opportunity and and
take some nice pictures with johnny
exactly and uh because we know that
they're like uh how to call it like the
virtual photography scene for cyberpunk
is really huge like we actually follow
it kind of closely like i personally
love uh like watching it uh watching
fans creations and what you guys can do
and stuff um so uh
now you can actually do it with johnny
as well you don't have to mod everything
basically
yeah so those new poses will be
available in the flashback quest like i
mentioned where you are actually playing
as johnny and
come on guys show us what you got we're
really curious what you can create with
that
so guys uh i don't know i think i think
we were we were talking for for a very
long time about about those things and
this is not even everything that is
going in the patch 1.5 yeah it's just a
bunch of
the most important changes or changes
that we wanted to show
er like the list is much longer actually
yeah okay
let's maybe sum up so we had a few dlcs
coming your way we have some extra
improvements and
pretty much now we can also see what
platform gets what right
yes so the dlcs are available for all
platforms most of the bug fixes
improvements rebalance stuff like that
also available on all possible platforms
there are a couple of uh of things that
won't be going to the last gen platforms
because because of the memory issues
mostly
but but
in general most of you will get the same
and here is a nice list of all of that
and this is going to be a pretty big
patch with all of that stuff it's going
to be around 50 gigabytes right it's a
chunky boy
boy yeah so once the part is live uh
most platforms will just get an
automatic update and you will be able to
to update the game and just just start
playing it on the new patch there is one
exception though which is a playstation
5 because the ps4 version that you are
now uh playing on your ps5 with
backwards compatibility
is actually a different version of the
game than the ps5 version which is
next-gen improved
so you're going to have to go to your
library and download the ps5 version
manually
yeah and it's worth mentioning that you
have to move your save from playful on
ps4
version of the game to the ps5
exactly and then you can move only one
right like philip
yeah yeah
that's right and
one more thing
we also on on ps5 we support dual
sensors uh
haptic feedback and adaptive triggers
and you you can try them when you are
driving cars
and uh
it's it's also supported in uh weapons
when you use them yeah it's also it's
also like supported in like sex scenes
uh from what i remember because i
implemented it pavo implemented
this in every sex scene
personally
toys
like so hey you were like the main qa
for this part right
designer qa
you're just running around with a
builder implementing that's not intersex
i just i just have a lot of hobbies you
know this is how it's called but
speaking about dual sense there's
there's more right because there's also
a speaker
yeah yeah so also also we use speaker in
the gamepad on ps5
so basically anything that is happening
in this head like getting phone calls
getting texts stuff like that it will be
it the sound will be coming out of out
of the controller speaker so it's like
closer to you
yes exactly that
okay so what now what now now i think we
it's it's time to to talk about uh the
difference in modes on uh next-gen
platforms right
yeah that's the important point so we
have performance versus ray tracing our
gameplay was in the performance mode am
i correct yes
so basically you you can either choose
between performance when you you get 60
fps uh or ray tracing with the uh with
the rtx uh enabled so basically whatever
you feel is more important for you when
you are playing the game uh you can
choose the correct mode to
uh to go to
easy as that easy easy as that but we
talked about next gen but we also have
something
uh i think important for pc players uh
correct me if i'm wrong of course oh yes
uh we added something like benchmark so
pretty much if you wanna you know check
how your your gpu your pc will actually
perform uh go to uh main settings then
press b as benchmark and then you'll
have
a section of like a few dynamic scenes
where the fps is pretty much like
constantly uh you know counted what you
know how it's going to be with rtx on
with rtx off
with the rss on performance balance
quality whatever you prefer you know
try them on find the best one for you
right now on the screen you can see that
this is um
this benchmark is
actually recorded it's come it comes
from
uh nvidia
geforce rtx 3090
it's on 2k in with the ss set on
performance
so you can see the fps in the top left
corner uh it's going to be you know you
know 70 80 something something around
that on on this um
on the settings but like i mentioned you
know play with the settings
exactly and i i think that that's the
key always you know to make the game uh
work best but amelia
so that benchmark is available for both
yes for all gpus out there exactly
exactly
about technical stuff uh one one thing
more um we support amd fidelity fx super
resolution now yes
finally i've got so many questions
all the time about this and i couldn't
say anything because i knew that we are
working on it and i wanted to tell you
but i couldn't but now i can yeah it's
there it's there it's there it's gonna
be in the game
okay guys i think i think we are almost
there uh we talked about all the changes
all the dlcs the next gen features how
to download the patch event but the
question remaining is when to download
the part
yep exactly
i think we can watch it
yes let's watch it let's watch it then
night city
man i [ __ ] love it
i was born here i live here in
downright refused to die anywhere else
170 people were killed in a cyber psycho
attacks
listen kid
there's one thing i can tell you about
this city
you either love it
or want to burn it
no middle ground
coming here is a crash course in the
survival of the fittest
the greediest
the most vile
and most corrupted dogs see this badge
that means i can do whatever the [ __ ] i
want
but behind the blinding lights and all
of the rot you might just discover a
beauty that can only be found here
night city is full of love
friendships
and family ties that run deeper than any
cyberware eddies can buy
zapper dumples and filth
in some ways night city never changes
the city's promise
not everyone's buying it
but if you want to know for sure you
just need to try it for yourself
yep oh
there are no mistakes there
exactly
the the patch the next gen update patch
1.5 with all of this school stuff that
we've been talking about since 4 p.m
is now available for everyone on all of
the platforms so guys exactly guys no
bullshitting just go and download it and
check it yourself really yes and while
we talking about checking it out
yourself
as you can see we also released a free
trial for all next gen uh platform so
playstation 5 series xbox series s and x
so if you still don't have the game now
is your chance to actually you know go
to the store uh per platform and
download it and try it yourself you know
if you if you actually are happy with
night city and if you like it
uh yeah and what's important well uh if
you
try the trial and then decide okay i
liked it i want to buy the game you can
actually transfer your save to the full
game so the five hours they won't be
wasted you don't lose anything it's it's
coming back you can continue playing on
the same stave yes
i know that like some of our players
will probably prove us that you know you
can even finish the game in five hours
but i mean you know that's fair if you
guys can do it just go for it really
like
check it out yourself try it out you
know love it or burn it really like
see you know what cyberpunk is
yes totally but like from like technical
point of view as well it's worth
mentioning uh
the trial will be available for you for
30 days like we mentioned five hours and
it's gonna be available for free
as
the patch patch is also free for you yes
right now
uh so
this is everything basically if you are
if you want to go and download the game
right now the patch 1.5 you can you can
just do it because it's already live and
in the meantime if you are looking to
get real into all of the changes that we
uh that we introduced in the patch which
we weren't able to tell you about all of
them in the stream
the patch notes are now available on
cyberpunk.net so you can you can go and
read them all
changes you have to find
that being said like during this stream
we have mostly focused on like
improvements and add-ons and like new
stuff or or things that you guys have
requested or like some bigger bugs let's
say but there was actually a ton of bug
fix that a lot of the pro departments
have been working on for past months and
that is nowhere to be found on the patch
notes you won't find it there you
actually only experience it in the game
we didn't want to like stuff the patch
notes with like thousands of entries
because that was pointless we only focus
on the most important uh things for you
so really the only way to experience
that is to get the free trial or look
put the game uh and check it out
so i think our job here is done you guys
just go download the patch check out the
patch notes and enjoy night city hope
you're gonna love it have fun everyone
and i'll see you around
yeah thank you guys so much i hope we'll
see each other in night city
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to tear it down again
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos